forward dri to the right
little in the background if you don't
believe that humans ever landed on the
moon you'd probably think that on July
16th 1969 a select group of government
officials a crew of filmmakers sworn to
secrecy and a famed Hollywood director
named Stanley kuri all gathered on a
sound stage in a military base deep in
the Nevada desert better known as Area
51 and here they pulled off the greatest
hoax in history you'd probably think
that astronauts or should I say actors
Buzz Aldren Neil Armstrong and Michael
Collins fled this rocket through a
secret passageway just before it took
off for space totally empty and you
would have to believe that the estimated
400,000 people who were involved in this
Mission were in on it all promising to
take this secret to their
grave
22% of Americans either don't believe
that we landed on the moon or Harbor
some doubt to advance the technology of
space flight we looked at the tapes and
the countless photos we talked to
astrophysicists meteorologists and NASA
historians to better understand the
moonlanding conspiracy how it started
what hoaxers use as their evidence and
what this belief teaches us about why
some conspiracies are so
enduring we are go for
launch you good at one
minute launch sequence engaged we are
go LIF off we have lift
off okay um real quick one of the big
Revolutions in science in recent decades
is an understanding of our minds we have
learned more and more that our minds are
actually just an organ called our brain
that are like any other muscle they can
be trained and retrained and redirected
and that doing so dramatically changes
how we see the world and how we
experience the world this is led to the
whole field of mental health which is
honestly not much different than
physical health with physical health we
do exercise to like keep our bodies
strong with mental health we're learning
that you can also do exercise it's
called therapy I've been doing therapy
now for several years and I can say with
total confidence that it is a life Cher
I mean I've reshaped how I see the world
and how I deal with difficult things we
all have difficult things and all of
this brings me to the sponsor of today's
video who is betterhelp betterhelp is a
platform that is making therapy more
accessible to millions of people thanks
to technology unlike the traditional way
of finding a therapist which often
involves calling people and going to
doctor's offices and sitting in Waiting
rooms with better help you just sign up
take a quiz you tell better help who you
are what you're struggling with what you
would like to achieve what you want to
change about your mind and then better
help pairs you with somebody in their
giant network of tens of thousands of
licensed therapists you can talk to them
by video chat you can talk to them by
phone which is what I do I do phone
therapy or you can talk to them by text
if you don't want to actually speak to
somebody if your therapist isn't a good
fit you can change and pick someone else
in their giant Network for me mental
health is now a non-negotiable I kind of
am blown away that I didn't do therapy
for most of my life but now I'm in
therapy and I deeply appreciate it it
has changed the way I see the world so
I'm very grateful that better help is
making therapy more accessible I'm also
grateful that they support our Channel
and our journalism and for sponsoring
today's video there's a link in my
description it's betterhelp.com Johny
Harris when you click that link it helps
support this channel but it also gets
you in on a discount you get 10% off
your first month of better help you can
try it out at a discount and see if
therapy will have as much of an impact
on your life as it has on mine thank you
better help for making therapy more
accessible to millions of people for
sponsoring today's video for supporting
our Channel and our journalism with that
let's dive back into this wild
conspiracy theory of the moon landing
Armstrong is on the Moon Neil Armstrong
standing on the surface of the Moon on
this July 20th
1969 that's one small step for man all
right so to give you some context on the
moonlanding I need to briefly explain
World War II and the Cold War which is
something I've kind of done a lot on
this channel so instead of me doing it
again we hired someone with an old timey
like radio Transatlantic accent to do it
instead buckle up for this
one in a world on the brink of
Destruction the United States of America
joined the Allied Forces in the second
world war in
1941 The Big Three the Soviet Union
Great Britain and now the USA versus the
Axis powers Italy Japan and Nazi Germany
they sure did put up a fight but the
Allied Powers came out on top you see
but then America and the USSR got real
cold with each other a tragic reversal
of the old Tales of enemies turned
lovers the Communists found the United
States to be exceedingly aggressive and
quite trigger happy with all their new
military power meddling in things they
ought to be keeping their noses out of
across the pond the capitalist United
States was fearful that the USSR was
hankering to spread their communism
across the whole globe
the war remained cold only because both
Powers had thousands of the most deadly
weapons Humanity had ever seen and
wouldn't dare use them against each
other it was something of a horrifying
stal
B soon the empires turned to other Feats
of Strength psychological warfare spying
Sports proxy wars and a race to advance
their Technologies and to top it all a
race like no other a race to space
spaceace at first it is very clear that
the Soviets are winning the
race they're launching dogs and plants
into space and bringing them back alive
they send up satellites that orbit the
Moon and take photos of The Far Side
that no one had seen before they even
put a human up into space to orbit
around the entire Earth the first space
flight would be made by a Soviet man the
US needs to catch up so President
Eisenhower creates a brand new
government agency dedicated entirely to
space and they eventually start to send
up satellites and even people but they
don't get someone to orbit the entire
Earth like the Russians did wamp wamp
the US is losing the space race and this
is where JFK gets up in front of the
nation and declares that the US is
setting a goal in this decade we shall
make up and move ahead he's declaring
what would surely be the ultimate Finish
Line in this Global race for power we
choose to go to the moon in this decade
an American astronaut eventually orbits
the earth not because they are easy
Russia then puts the first woman in
space while also getting the first
person to walk in space but because they
are hard the NASA teams are pulling all
nighters year after year trying to
figure out how they're going to make
good on JFK's big promise to somehow get
a man on the Moon by the end of the
decade things are heating up time is
running out
and then launch sequence engaged we
are you
read NASA's disaster was a major setback
but the stakes were too high to give up
the Space Race had become much more than
a technological rivalry winning the race
to the moon would Mean winning the
ideological war for the world would it
be communism or
capitalism they couldn't give up now so
they kept
going in 1968 NASA finally gets a
spaceship the Apollo 8 to orbit the Moon
with astronauts aboard There's Hope
Russia is able to exchange a crew in
space for both sides a moon trip
suddenly seems Within
Reach but who will get there first I
Richard Bill house next to solom
[Music]
[Applause]
swear and then after hundreds of
millions of dollars and countless
focused hours by the country's brightest
Minds comes a morning on a summer day in
Houston Texas in
ch three men buckle up hundreds of
millions of people around the world find
themselves glued to their television
sets because the greatest achievement of
mankind might happen then starts the 5 4
3 2 1 zero all engine running liftoff we
have a liftoff 32 minutes past the hour
liftoff on Apollo
11 Tower cleared here we got a roll
program Neil Armstrong reporting the
rolling pitch program which puts Apollo
11 on proper
heading rolls complete and a pitch is
program the rocket heads towards the
finish line that pearly orb that humans
had stared at and mythologized about
fixated on and they're finally going to
touch it just say the word and I'll
throw a lasso around and pull it
down 4 days and 200,000 mil later it's
July 20th
1969 months before JFK's deadline was up
two of the three astronauts disconnect
from the orbiting ship and descend onto
the moon's surface and
then there you go oh it's beautiful Mike
really
is these fumes the race had clearly been
won a line had been crossed not just for
the global superpower who did this but
for all humans who had just taken their
Obsession for exploration to new
heights but right away after this event
even though it was broadcast on live
television for the whole world to see
there were Rumblings of
doubt about a year after the landing you
start to see newspaper articles casting
doubt that any of this actually happened
2 years after the landing we see James
Bond running away from a bunch of
security guards through the Nevada
desert when he somehow stumbles upon a
secret moonlanding film set resulting in
this moon buggy car chase thing through
the desert it was all a tongue-and-cheek
reference to this budding conspiracy
that the whole thing was faked a few
years later a former US Navy officer and
Apollo Rocket technical writer comes out
with this
book I think it was an intuitive feeling
that what was being shown was not real
the book is a long evaluation of
evidence that claims that we never
actually went to the moon this book
makes the case that the moon landing was
so political that the us having failed
to develop a feasible plan to get to the
moon pulled off this secretive staging
of the event all as a propaganda play to
get ahead of the Soviets and he
emphasizes the point that you know it's
the Cold War it's not that far fetch
that the US government would come up
with some deception campaign in the name
of beating communism which is like
totally fair actually but that's not
evidence that's just speculation he does
go on to present a bunch of photos and
explanations that turn into the
foundation of what would become a
widespread theory that the moonlanding
was faked the lunar Landings were more
than likely fabricated why wouldn't The
Landing be fake you know why wouldn't we
fake that we do not land men on the Moon
the
Moon yeah it's fake and I would bet my
life on it this is actually the reason I
wanted to make this video is I wanted to
understand what the foundation of this
conspiracy theory actually was the
people who truly earnestly believe it
what do they think happened here I'm not
going to go through all of the evidence
and theories here because they're kind
of all over the place let me show you
some of the major ones the first major
one starts here how come there aren't
any stars in this photo if there's no
atmosphere or light pollution on the
moon shouldn't this photo look like
this well it turns out that if you want
to capture the Stars even on on the moon
you have to open up your camera for a
very long time and let a bunch of light
in trust me I know this because I spent
months of my life trying to photograph a
Galaxy and I learned a lot about how not
to photograph stars and let me just tell
you it's it's a lot harder than it looks
when I was doing that I was opening up
my shutter for 30 seconds and I took
hundreds of images just to get this one
shot so when you're on the bright moon
and you're trying to photograph a bunch
of guys in bright white reflective suits
you're not opening up your shutter for a
very long time you're not letting in a
bunch of light there's basically no
chance of getting a decent shot of the
stars in this environment but you get
something I mean if you take the photo
and blast up the brightness you can kind
of see some traces of the Stars if you
really need to do that okay but what
about these Shadows some of these
Shadows go this way and some go this way
shouldn't the Shadows be parallel if
they're all coming from One Source the
sun yes the only light source in this
photo
is the Sun but you have to remember that
light bounces off things especially
white things so you have light bouncing
off of lots of different surfaces which
is one reason the Shadows look a little
weird oh and remember that you're
looking at light that was filtered
through a lens a camera lens distorts
the direction of things depending on how
wide or tight it is okay but what about
this flag this flag is waving but
there's no wind on the Moon yes the flag
is kind of w waving but remember that
this isn't a normal flag NASA had to
make a custom flag for the Apollo
missions that had a horizontal Rod right
up here so that the flag wouldn't look
like this it had to look nice and
American and patriotic you had to be
able to see it so when the astronauts
were sticking the flag in the lunar soil
the motion of that movement caused the
material to move and it kind of looks
like it's
waving okay but look how they're moving
this is so natural it's almost like
they're being pulled up by a wire oh and
look did you catch that that looks like
a wire okay wait just confession here I
was watching all of these conspiracy
documentaries like while we're doing
this story and they're like incredibly
tantalizing this is the one that
actually kind of got me I was like wait
a minute they are moving really weird
the motion is so off-kilter it looks
like they're being like dragged by a
wire so to figure this out we actually
talked to a physicist and a
meteorologist who helpfully explained
just how different life in one 16th
Earth's gravity is I mean think about it
our intuition for everything we know is
calibrated to Earth's gravity it's
everything we've ever known it's how our
brains interpret the world it's how our
muscles calibrate to the world so when
you're watching these videos of these
astronauts in suits that weigh 180 lbs
clunking around with their Earth gravity
trained muscles on the moon you see some
really weird movements but I mean who
knows maybe the two scientists we talked
to are actually in on it maybe they're
some of the half million Americans who
were paid by the government to keep the
hopes alive all so that we could feel
like America is better than the Soviet
Union in 1969 maybe could be okay listen
I'm not going to go through every single
one of these theories there's a lot of
evidence out there like why isn't there
exhaust on this Flame or why did the
eagle Lander not leave a crater what
about the radiation exposure that these
astronauts would have gotten what about
Neil Armstrong's bootprint or the Lost
Tapes don't get me started on Lost Tapes
we actually had a whole section in the
script about the Lost tapes and
ultimately it didn't make the cut now
listen I want it to be clear that you
should not be ashamed if you actually
want answers to these questions
especially in a time where all of us are
kind of renegotiating our relationship
with trust in governmental institutions
but I will tell you that after earnestly
looking into this stuff none of the
presented evidence comes anywhere close
to the burden of proof and evidence I
would need to see to believe that the
moonlanding was a hoax I will put
resources in our source doc of the many
instances of astrophysicists and
scientists walking you through all this
stuff I think it's useful to look at
before we move on with our story of The
Conspiracy Theory let me use this moment
to say a word about human neurology and
visual information something I think
about a lot for me when I sit through
the evidence-based debunk on these
theories which is something we did for
this story it helps me understand the
limits of human senses our eyes and ears
and logical thinking brains were
optimized for very different problems
than evaluating the physics of our
fellow Homo sapiens jumping around on a
baby Planet 200,000 Mi away like we're
not set up for this stuff going through
the conspiracy theory and then going
through the debunks reminds me why we as
a species developed other ways of
sensing other ways of measuring and
knowing things about the world other
tools that aren't as intuitive to us but
that extend our power to know know
things that are real that are true if
you don't lean on these tools in other
words if you don't look to science in
your evaluation and instead rely on your
optic nerve feeding grainy pixels into
your great ape brain I think we can all
agree that you'll take for truth things
that are not true okay neurology section
is over let's get back to it if you're
going to go down this rabbit hole and
indulge your conspiracy mind like I did
for this story let's talk about what
people think actually happened here like
all of this footage and all of these
photos what do the moon hoaxers think
we're looking
at one of the most common explanations
is that the US afraid that they would be
embarrassed in front of the global stage
because they would fail on JFK's big
promise hired a famed Hollywood director
Stanley Kubrick who had just released a
groundbreaking Space movie and they used
his visual skills to deceive the world
filming the moon landing on a sound
stage in the middle of the desert I mean
look this rock has a perfect sea on it
is that a prop these misaligned Shadows
they explain as studio lights the flag
was waving because there was air
conditioning in the studio and these
photos were actually taken by Stanley
Kubrick's crew all of these movements
they say were done with wires and slow
motion and that black starless sky is
just a black cloth
backdrop that's one small step for
man
in 1977 The Conspiracy Theory had spread
enough that NASA had to come out and
issue a fact sheet responding to the
claims the first sentence of which is
just yes astronauts did land on the moon
but then a movie comes out in 1977 about
the government faking a space mission
this time to Mars to save face to the
American people but the space race was
over it wasn't the focus anymore and
eventually so was the Cold War this
moonlanding Theory became more and more
Fringe but inevitably like any other
good tantalizing conspiracy theory it
was eventually repackaged and put into
one of these really spooky cheesy cable
news documentaries in 2001 Fox News
aired this documentary on conspiracy
theory did we land on the
Moon it was basically just a repackaging
of all the old theories but for a new
audience but now it was the dawn of the
internet age and NASA had to respond to
this Fox News doc by reissuing the fact
sheet that they issued in 1977 but this
time on a website an innocent foreshadow
to combating information on the internet
they had no idea what was coming the doc
gave the conspiracy new Energy new
followers and soon a conspiracy theorist
was following Buzz Aldren around a hotel
pestering him and demanding him to swear
on the Bible that he landed on the moon
and Buzz punched him in the face shortly
after that a French mockumentary came
out laying out evidence that Stanley
kubri did film The moonlanding the
problem is people thought it was real
there's a fake documentary not a real
documentary but a fake like a
mockumentary where he's admitting and
people are talking about you you seen
that one no but that makes sense yeah a
lot of people like dude you didn't even
know there's an actual real interview
with him where he admits that he fake
the moon landing but it's not it's just
it's
fake so today the conspiracy lives on in
a world of increasing science skepticism
and on an Internet that fuels pretend
information and to a demographic that is
more and more mistrusting of
institutional knowledge one poll found
that in 2019 11% of American Millennials
believed that the moon landing was
staged it's become a particularly
durable conspiracy theory because it has
all of the ingredients of a good
conspiracy theory it's shadowy
government antagonist with political
motives it leans on the human eye and
brain as the primary measuring tool for
the evidence and when you believe in
stuff like this it feels good like
you're in on a secret so let me just end
this video by telling you why I know we
landed on the Moon the Moon on Theon on
Theon you are looking at a very thin
section of moon rock magnified 500 times
first off we brought back 900 lb of
rocks during the Apollo missions the
Soviets who were our technological and
geopolitical enemies eventually sent a
robot to the Moon to collect samples of
their own these precious rocks are sent
out to scientists and Educators 400
times a year to be studied and examined
and it has been verified by a lot of
different people who have no motive to
lie that these rocks were developed in
an environment completely rid of oxygen
also the Soviets themselves corroborated
the moon landing and acknowledged that
it happened I mean the Soviet leader
kind of begrudgingly complimented the
the US and they published like a tiny
little blurb in one of their newspapers
but like they lost and they admitted
they lost also if I'm going to rely on
just my human brain Logic for a second
here think about it there were hundreds
of thousands of people who were involved
in the Apollo missions scientists
engineers physicists policy makers
mathematicians all working day and night
towards this goal obsessing over every
detail and then monitoring every step of
the way from Houston Texas to the
surface of the Moon and back communic
with the astronauts the whole time so
imagine two Texas Motor Speedway
stadiums full of the brightest mines in
the country all in on the biggest
deception of all time without a single
leak and finally if you insist on using
your eyeballs as your only sensors that
you will accept as proof just look at
this this photo was taken by a telescope
orbiting the moon these are astronaut
and buggy tracks here on the surface of
the Moon you can even see the buggies
parking spot right here and if you think
that this photo that yes was originally
taken by NASA but many other photos have
come out by other space stations that
show physical evidence of humans on the
moon if you think that this is still the
government like 40 years later the kids
and grandkids of the Apollo people still
photoshopping pictures to keep up this
elaborate
ruse I don't know what would convince
you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone thanks for watching um this
was a fun video to work on we have so
much archive like luckily there's
amazing footage for this and we got to
use a teaspoon of it for this but really
we'll put some links in the description
and in the source DOC for a place you
can go to look at all of this amazing
footage and photography I want to
quickly tell you about The Newsroom
which is our patreon where all of you
support the journalism we're doing here
you can go to The Newsroom and get
access to a behind the scenes Vlog that
we do every month so it is a an insight
into everything we do here you can meet
the team you can see the process of how
we are building this um journalism
Studio on YouTube uh you also get access
to my scripts you get access to Tom Fox
music that you can use royaltyfree and
it's just a way that you can support the
journalism we're trying to do here you
also can check out the new poster that
we just launched it is called all maps
are wrong I designed it with the help of
some of my friends and um it is
something I've been wanting to do for a
long time it has all of the map
projections that are the way that that
we take the Earth which is a sphere and
put it onto a flat plane which is called
a map and in doing so you stretch the
map inevitably and it means that all
maps are wrong and this poster is kind
of an homage to that we have LS and
presets which is how we color our photos
and videos and we recently launched a
tip line a place where we can hear from
you on what stories you think we should
tell whether you have access to specific
data or evidence or knowledge that you
think would make a comp telling story or
an investigation that needs to be done
or just a story that you think is
undercovered and that needs um
explanation information about that is in
the description we always love to hear
from you to make our reporting more
holistic more representative and
stronger so thank you for your
submissions thank you all for being here
I will see you in the next
one
oh